hey guys it is Thursday the day and
you're watching games what news my name
is Jess I'm Dan and here's a fun fact
about dan dan last night I bought
tickets to a screening of a film in New
Zealand
I in fact live in Australia yeah so that
was a pretty good thing that I did two
new games have joined the xbox backwards
compatibility library today and I think
you can all like these ones well maybe
they're very very ambitious the two Xbox
360 games to join the over 400 games
already part of the program are fable
anniversary and fable to pub games fable
anniversary is a remaster of the first
fable and features improved graphics and
new UI achievements and everything from
the expanded version The Lost Chapters
that was released in 2005 fable 2 pub
games on the other hand is an Xbox Live
Arcade title that released I heard of
fable 2 and allows you to earn money and
items that carried over into the
ambitious sequels if you own these ones
digitally they'll be available in your
ready to download section right now or
if your favorite a bursary disc is still
floating around you can pop that into
your Xbox one and get played if you've
been hearing about the pile of games on
their way to Nintendo switch and
thinking it might be time to pick
yourself up one of those a Nintendo are
trying to make that easier for you a
report from digi x has indicated that
Nintendo has raised its orders for the
switch up to 2 million units a month due
to consumer demand sources from the
upstream supply chain also indicated
that as a result the publisher should
hit its annual shipping target of 20
million units for 2017 that's a whole
lot of switches Nintendo will also begin
selling the console in China early next
year so that will add another big bump
by the end of June 2017 and tender had
sold four point seven million switches
it was actually pretty it's actually
pretty easy to find them in Australia
70s NES meaning I don't know if we're
just like you know normally we're an
anomaly to most things temperature time
you are definitely I would normally to
most human things but yeah it's been
very easy to get a Nintendo products in
Australia recently so hopefully this
means that they're getting rid of the
trend of making all their stuff super
hard to come by
although I never got one of those cool
Guardian amiibos which I would love so
if anyone's the semi one for free I'll
hit you back with maybe some banana
bread I'm pretty good at making been out
of it for two Motorsports 7 released
earlier this week and fans aren't super
stoked like the spokes of a wheel with
the game's VIP pass
with you if that wasn't matted in Forza
Motorsport 6 buying the extra VIP pass
gave double racing credits on all races
in Forza Motorsport 7 however the pass
was changed pretty substantially the
pass which is available as part of the
$100 Ultimate Edition all for $20
separately only gave access to 5 mod
cards that double racing credits for 5
races which means there's now a maximum
cap for raping double rewards 25 times
unfortunately the stores description of
the past didn't make any mention in this
developer turn 10 was quick to address
the issue and updated the listing and
change Heather VIP pass functions in
Forza Motorsport 7 the new system will
revert to the same system as Motorsport
6 and allow you to earn double xp for
all races
anyone who has bought the VIP pass will
also receive 1 million credits and for
additional fort sir edition cars which
are available to download right now from
the in-game message sound that's
everything we've got for you today do
remember to pop by same time tomorrow
for our top 5 stories of the entire week
and more great joke just fella like it
in our day hey-ya plain Zelda yeah yeah
what he doesn't do any kicks yeah can
you do the solid snake punch the CQC
bitter medal you sell it for you that
for you moaning do you want to take